- Hey guys, how's it going? It's Justine.
Happy Cinco de Mayo!
Of course, to celebrate,
we are going to be
making tiny tacos today.
The first time I did one of these little
Yummy Nummy videos years ago,
it was the most fun I've
had in a really long time,
and not sure why.
I don't really know if I enjoy it,
the food isn't even that good,
and it kinda smells funny.
But for whatever reason,
they are really fun to make.
But this is meat, tiny taco meat.
How's that gonna taste?
I already know how it's gonna taste.
It's not gonna taste good.
It also has a little limeade drink.
Ooh, spicy!
Let's get started!
(festive trumpet music)
(plastic crinkling)
Got all of our things here.
See here's the problem.
Usually I do this with two people,
and they'll read the directions
while I try to figure
out what's happening.
So now that I'm alone,
I gotta read it myself.
Remove the tray, packets,
and utensils from packaging.
Use a scissor to cut.
(cutting)
Hmm!
We've got our scoops,
we've got our spoons,
got our little teeny tiny glass!
It's so cute!
Open the tortilla O90 package.
Here's the tortilla package.
(cutting)
This is disgusting.
Six round scoops, one, six.
And then we do two square waters, okay!
Now we're going to mix this up.
We got our little dough here,
now we're gonna separate this
into two little sections,
and we're gonna jam this into
our little taco template.
15 seconds, on the clock.
Oh, done!
This smells like something
that no one should ever eat,
but guess what, I'm gonna eat it.
And so is Nick!
- [Nick] What?
- And so is nick!
- What?
Now, we're gettin' into the meat, guys.
We need four scoops of meat powder. (gags)
Let's open up our meat bag.
(Nick laughs)
(gags)
Four scoops of taco meat.
- [Woman] You're four scoops of taco meat.
- One, four.
Three squares of water.
Three squares of water, all right.
Two, mix up this meat, wow! (gags)
Wait a minute, we have to
microwave this tray for 10 seconds
and then immediately begin
chopping up the taco meat
within the tray,
using your spoon so the
meat looks ground up.
(microwave door slams)
(beeping)
Immediately start chopping!
I'm thinking of a song.
It goes a little something like
♪ Do do do do, I wanna meet that dad ♪
♪ do do do do, what's that dad like ♪
♪ Do do do do, do do do do ♪
♪ Do do do do do do do do do ♪
♪ Ha ha ha ♪
- So we're gonna put our
meat inside of there.
Next, we are making the taco sauce.
Two scoops of sauce, one scoop of water.
(melodic piano music)
Doesn't that look delicious?
Nick is throwing up
everywhere as we speak.
Now we are scooping the,
oh I didn't make the cheese mixture.
I was supposed to do a cheese mixture?
Oh, okay well there's
also a cheese mixture.
I skipped a step.
Oh, oh wow!
That smells delicious!
One, in you go.
The cheese mixture is being mixed.
It smells just like
instant mac and cheese mix.
So I was supposed to scoop
the cheese and mixtures
into this little bag, but I
think that's not necessary.
We're just gonna dump it in.
Mm-mm, extra saucy.
This looks very good.
Oh I gotta make the drink.
One little scoop of
the fizzy drink powder.
So I'm just gonna put a little
in, I'm not gonna measure
'cause I am really not
about that measuring life.
I'm just gonna dump some of
this in there, fizzy, fizzy!
Fizzy, fizzy coco puff, pass it to me now!
Drink it up and, don't know.
It's fizzin'.
Look at this, does this not look like
the most delicious meal
that you've ever seen?
Now we have to eat it.
- [Nick] What?
- So you're gonna have to come over here.
Do you wanna be on camera?
Here's my cheesy, cheesy taco.
That's your non-cheesy taco.
- Okay.
- Cheers to the freaking weekend.
- Happy Cinco de Mayo!
- You go first.
- I mean it surprisingly tastes like meat.
- Yeah, yeah it's really not bad.
- But I wouldn't say it's good.
It's really sticky.
- The tortilla is gooey.
- Did you say you wanted the rest of this,
this has cheese on it.
You like cheese, like cheese, like cheese?
Mini cheese, tiny cheese, tiny taco.
- No, nobody wants to go to that party.
- Uh uh, no! (slurps)
- Oh we're doing shots?
- Yeah go ahead.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Woman] Is that tequila?
- Yeah!
- No, it's fizzy drink!
- It tastes like a flat sprite.
- Ah well, happy Cinco de Mayo.
- Happy mini Cinco de Mayo to you too.
- Did you enjoy it?
- Yeah, it was great, it was so worth it.
(both laugh)
- It was so worth however
long it took me to make this,
which actually was a lot
longer than I thought.
- I'm gonna go back behind the--
- Okay, oh yeah, yeah. I'll
see you guys in my next video.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you guys have a
wonderful Cinco de Mayo.
Let me know if you guys
would like me to make
something like this again.
I think I enjoyed it.
I'm pretty sure I did.
I didn't enjoy the taste,
but I enjoyed the process.
I'll see you guys later, bye!